social aviation industry will need more
than six hundred thousand new pilots
over the next 20 years that according to
a recent forecast by Boeing so this is
an industry that has been through a lot
of turmoil in recent years eight news
now reporter Brian whale takes us inside
the world of Aviation to show us what's
being done to address the issue right
here in Las Vegas
the guys that were flying back then are
now retiring all all at once okay that's
one thing number two is the the demand
for air Travelers skyrocketed and number
three third world countries that weren't
even doing that much flying or flying
like every day Ron Kelly and his company
Las Vegas Flight Academy helped train
Pilots but now he has a more important
mission of inspiring the Next Generation
to take to the skies we're going into
the inner cities to the schools to bring
in more women and minorities into
Aviation and the number one thing I get
from them is that they don't even know
that this is a possibility for them and
once they do their eyes go like this
Airlines like Las Vegas based Allegiant
are also creating Pathways for people to
become Pilots Partnerships with
four-year universities that have 141
flight schools we have a great
partnership with Spartan that's our
altitude program it's kind of what
traditionally is called the Zero to Hero
program it's a flight school will take
you from no flight time all the way
through your commercial a lot of people
may not know that some of the flight
training for Allegiant happens right
here in Las Vegas and I got to hop in
the pilot seat for an inside look inside
this flight simulator so the strip on
our right hand side
so now you're gonna go ahead and roll to
the left
until you can get that bar back and
you're going to pitch down to get that
horizontal bar back onto that yellow
Square it does come with long hours and
it's intensive training some things that
people don't realize not only is there a
lot of training for it's not just one
and done it's throughout your entire
career it's a skill set that you hone
over and over and over again there's
also a medical component to it it takes
about a year to get your certificates
and ratings but then you need to get up
to 1500 hours before you can take the
controls of an airline nice landing
safe and sound flight schools and
aircraft rental company all in aviation
hosting an open house event in an effort
to Showcase stem careers in aviation it
is at the Henderson Executive Airport
Thursday at 4 pm